on s'arrête sur le volet économique de
l'intervention du chef de l'état hier
soir d'abord avec cette réforme des
retraites
elle aura bien lieu nous dit emmanuel
macron ce qui a sérieusement irriter la
gauche vous l'imaginez on voit pourquoi
avec nos invités dans un instant d'abord
les réactions au sénat avec audrey fait
état d' emmanuel macron remet son
costume de réformateurs et demande à
jean castex de travailler à nouveau dès
la rentrée avec les partenaires sociaux
sur la réforme des retraites pour le
reste le calendrier est plus floue
puisque d'après le président la réforme
sera lancée quand l'épidémie sera sous
contrôle et la reprise bien assurée à
quelques mois de la présidentielle les
sénateurs comprennent deux choses soit
elle se fera dans l'urgence soit et
c'est plus certain elle n'aura pas lieu
sous ce mandat la droite sénatoriale
fustige une manoeuvre pour asphyxier les
républicains c'est encore du en même
temps ou non par on dit il faut faire
une réforme puis après on dit pourquoi
on la fait pas effectivement les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour que
vous puissiez discuter sereinement de
cet équilibre du système de retraite
donc on reporte plus tard pour la
majorité présidentielle
emmanuel macron reste surtout fidèle à
lui même c'est l'ambition réformatrice
aussi du président macron qui qui plaît
aux français qui a plu aux français en
2010 est donc je pense que c'est
important qu'ils puissent aller jusqu'au
bout effectivement ce de ses réformes
et s'ils commencent à rentrer en
campagne avec cette allocution c'est
tant mieux
la campagne a commencé à droite l ai
commencé à gauche il est normal que le
président lui aussi pas 10
voilà les axes j'ai pas pu aboutir
jusqu'à présent sur la réforme des
retraites mais je maintient le cap
lors de son allocution le président a
évoqué la fin des régimes spéciaux une
retraite à 1000 euros minimum pour les
carrières complètes et un départ plus
tardif pour la socialiste monique lubin
ces annonces n'avaient pas lieu d'être
dans une déclaration sanitaires et elles
ne font que rajouter du doute au doute
est-ce qu'on va annuler totalement la
première réforme qui était prévu est-ce
qu'on va repartir sur autre chose
complète enfants de céréales tout cela
contribue à
très anxiogène pour les français seule
certitude d'après elle à en croire le
président l'âge de départ en retraite ne
sera pas reculer dès le mois d'octobre
comme le demandaient certains ministres
avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir stéphanie ville est bienvenue vous
êtes économiste et auteur de ce livre
est crise économique 2020 vers un
nouveau monde point d'interrogation
frédéric farah bienvenue à vous
également
vous êtes professeur de sciences
économiques et sociales et coauteur avec
thomas porcher de ce livre taffetas
l'accord du plus fort merci à tous les
deux d'être avec vous d'abord peut-être
le calendrier de cette réforme des
retraites pour laurent berger c'est très
clair elle est renvoyée après la
présidentielle d'après ce qu'il a
compris des propos d' emmanuel macron il
nous dit la réforme est renvoyée après
la présidentielle et c'est une position
de sagesse vous avez compris la même
chose et fanny et je pense qu'en
situation de juste reprises il serait
malaisé de d'arriver avec une réforme
qui pourrait braquer les les
consommateurs je vous rappelle que là on
mise pour la relance la reprise
économique sur la capacité des français
à puiser dans leur bas de laine
toute cette épargne forcée qui a mis qui
a été mis de côté pendant la période de
confinement une couvre feu donc il
faudrait pas braquer cette cet élan là
on voit que la depuis le début de l'été
mais ça va un peu mieux donc pour que
cesse poursuivre il faut il faut ne pas
adresser des messages qui pourrait être
angoissant et gai et qui pourraient
braquer les français dans leur envie de
dans des coupes dans de profiter de nous
on a déjà braqué certains quand même un
frédéric farah parce que le calendrier
n'est pas très clair laurent berger pour
lui c'est après la présidentielle vous
avez compris la même chose vous écouter
toutes les façons ça va devoir avoir
lieu peut-être après la présidentielle
parce que là un pour la reprise
économique je suis d'accord c'était la
meilleure des choses de il ya une
campagne électorale qui se prépare je ne
sais pas si c'est la meilleure des
choses est de toutes les façons elle et
elle est présente pour en avoir la
certitude
si vous voulez le gouvernement français
a envoyé à l'union européenne un
programme de stabilisation 2021 et 2027
à la commission quand on lit ce document
il est clairement indiqué de manière
très prudente par le gouvernement
français que la réforme même s'il a pas
pu être immédiatement fait elle va
devoir être fait donc c'est quand même
un engagement auprès de l'union
européenne au moment même où il ya un
plan dit de relance de nouvelle
génération dans l'union européenne donc
il faut à la fois on allie pour le
gouvernement tenir deux choses ne pas
braquer l'opinion qui évidemment regarde
ses traits forme avec beaucoup de
réserve
elle a mobilisé autrefois et deux à des
engagements vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne qui ont été clairement
indiquée et qui aussi conditionne à leur
manière
l'obtention de ces fameux fonds
européens il ya quand même une
conditionnalité donc effectivement elle
mais là ça c'est important pardonnez moi
parce que emmanuel macron le dit pas
comme ça hein
ce sont ceux qui arrivent à décrypter
qui s'y connaissent un peu des gens
comme vous éclairer économistes qui
arrive à dire attendez en fait il va la
faire et s'ils engagent parce que
bruxelles la demande c'est quand même
pas tout à fait la même chose
oui c'est à dire je crois que il ya des
documents qui sont un peu aride mais
qu'il faut lire et ce document je parle
de stabilisation et se trouve sur le
site de la commission c'est en pdf c'est
gratuit c'est accessible à tout le monde
et dans ce document vous trouvez des
choses très intéressantes et sans
vouloir trop avancé dans le débat vous
avez cette question de la retraite ou
clairement il est dit et d'autre part il
y a un peu plus loin dans le document il
est indiqué comment les dépenses
publiques vont progresser plus lentement
pour pouvoir éviter que déficits et
dettes augmenter dans un passage il est
clairement indiqué concernant
l'assurance chômage que les nouvelles
règles qui doivent se mettre en place ou
qui devait se mettre en place à partir
du 1er juillet participerez de cet
effort
donc si on libye
ce qui est dit dans ce document ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire on indiquerait pas la
modification des modalités de calcul des
indemnités chômage si elle avait
vocation au contraire accroître donc
c'est pour cela que à moins que le
gouvernement français ça je ne crois pas
un seul instant soit pas sérieux et
envoi des documents à bruxelles comme ça
pour le plaisir quand même je veux dire
il faut être sérieux dans la sphère
fouzia c'est un document qui engagent la
parole de la france
d'autant qu' on a eu que notre dette
publique c'était s'était un peu emballé
avec la dette kobina on est passé à une
aide sur public qui va atteindre 120% du
pipe donc on est obligé de montrer une
forme de rigueur budgétaire pour au sein
de la zone euro adresser un signal de
bon sens en fait sur le fond tels
qu'emmanuel macron la formule est fière
elle vous va cette réforme je récite un
tout petit peu ces mots parce que nous
vivons plus longtemps il nous faudra
travailler plus longtemps et partir à la
retraite plus tard il faudra prendre en
compte la difficulté des métiers mais
progressivement sur plusieurs années et
par un système qui fait la différence
selon le travail réellement exercées et
donc l'âge de départ doit être plus
tardif
ça semblait tourner fendent l'air plus
simples que celles qui avaient été
proposées en fait c'est une réforme
budgétaire c'est à dire limiter le coût
le poids de la retraite dans la dépense
totale ce qui a un peu décevant c'est
que au départ je vous rappelle lorsque
emmanuel macron est arrivée à l'elysée
il avait annoncé qu'il ne toucherait pas
le départ d'aj à la retraite mais qu'il
allait mener une réforme systémique
donc pour ma part y ait une forme de
déception c'est à dire qu'on s'attendait
à une à revisiter notre système pour le
rendre plus juste plus équitable
il parle encore de ses 42 régimes
spéciaux qui en fait
à ces fonds collectivement basculer le
système dans un état déficitaires alors
qu'en face on a quand même dans le
secteur privé le régime complémentaire
agirc arrco qui fonctionne quand même
relativement bien puisqu'il n'est
absolument pas déficit et elle ne le
peut pas l'être
réglementairement parlant donc il y
avait un système en face le système
agirc arrco qui fonctionne qui est un
système par points et au départ en fait
emmanuel macron voulait s'inspirer de ce
système ce qui est un peu dommage c'est
que effectivement on yare un rétro
pédalage et que finalement on va se
retrouver avec une réforme paramétrique
on a connu qui est l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation et marisol touraine
mais de manière progressive je crois là
mais ça se comprend effectivement du
fait de notre allongement de la durée de
notre espérance de vie
là aussi il ya quand même une logique
économique il faut intégrer on vit plus
longtemps
c'est une bonne nouvelle donc il faut
effectivement travailler plus longtemps
pour permettre aux personnes à la
retraite de pouvoir être financés et
d'eric farro j'ai apporté quelques
nuances qui sont les suivantes c'est à
dire que historiquement sur le temps
long qu'est ce qu'on observe si on
observe des évolutions inverses c'est à
dire que plus le temps que l'on consacre
au travail se réduit et plus d'espérance
de vie augmente c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on a observé c'est à dire c'est le
contraire commencer c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui
de mémoire un homme vers 1850 ou une
femme travaille en moyenne trois mille
six cents heures
well annuelle aujourd'hui un homme ou
une femme travaille un peu plus autour
de 1500 1560
c'était aussi le système de santé oui
oui mais met d'accord mais en même temps
nous avons nous vivons plus longtemps en
meilleure santé
les conditions de travail se sont
améliorées les conditions du travail aux
6 à ses premières choses deuxième chose
si l'espérance de vie continue à
augmenter l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé elle est depuis dix ans elle
stagne donc c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
on a une espérance de vie qu'il faut
relativiser par rapport à ça sachant
qu'en plus l'espérance de vie n est pas
la même pour toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qu'un
cadre vit plus longtemps effectivement
qu'un ouvrier donc si tous les deux on
les fait partir en même temps à la
retraite
ben c'est pas juste parce que quelqu'un
un ouvrier en moyenne va mourir sept ans
plus tôt qu'un cadre donc par conséquent
effectivement il va pas bénéficier des
mêmes flux de revenus que le cadre bon
ça c'est un d'autre part le corps le
conseil la crise des retraites nous dit
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous dit clairement que le système
aujourd'hui et bien n'est pas menacée
son dernier rapport nous l'indiquent
clairement que d'autre part il ya
quelque chose qui inquiète le corps est
pas que le corps c'est que toutes les
réformes dit paramétrique depuis 1981
une réforme paramétrique c'est celle qui
agit et qui veulent agir par exemple sur
la durée de cotisation sur les modalités
de calcul de la retraite
et comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas
systémiques toutes ces réformes là ont
eu pour effet petit à petit de grignoter
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
il suffit de penser par exemple retraite
aux réformes 87 séguin 93 balladur ou
désormais les retraites ne sont plus
indexés sur les salaires mais sur les
prix ce qui a eu pour effet
effectivement d'entraîner
progressivement et dégradations de
pouvoir d'achat des salariés
alors que notre grande conquête avait
été à partir après 1968 ça a été de
réduire la pauvreté historique
c'est-à-dire la pauvreté des vieux
travailleurs donc aujourd'hui le risque
même si la pauvreté à un jeu ni c'est
qu'à terme on est un appauvrissement des
retraités donc je trouve que cette
retraite c'est réforme des retraites
arrive
bizarrement alors que les signaux
concernant ce système ne sont pas des
signaux rouges urgence urgence
je trouve ça a quelque peu paradoxale et
je pense qu'il faut bien distinguer
l'espérance de vie et l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé
il ya une autre réforme qui entrera bien
en vigueur à en croire le chef de l'état
c'est celle de l'assurance chômage
souvenez vous elle devait complètement
s'appliquer dès le 1er juillet le
conseil d'état jugé que le contexte
économique était trop incertain pour le
moment une décision que n'a pas comprise
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'est exprimé sur france
info ce matin à côté j'ai lu avec
beaucoup d'attention les considérant le
du conseil d'état je dois dire que j'ai
mal à comprendre leur évaluation la
situation économique mais dont acte en
revanche nous maintenons l'application
de cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui doit inciter au retour à l'activité
pénalisées aussi la butte contrats
courts dont on voit bien que c'est un
des problèmes de l'économie française au
1er octobre
stéphanie villers sont maintenant la
date du 1er octobre
le gouvernement essaye de forcer un peu
le passage sans trop savoir non plus
quel sera le contexte économique d'ici
quelques mois oui je pense que là pour
le coup il prend un risque on ne sait
pas vraiment dans quel état d'esprit
sera la rentrée économique de 2
septembre à cause de ce variant bien sûr
ce que change tout et voilà c'est à dire
que on ne sait pas si on va devoir faire
face à cette quatrième vague qui de si
la vaccination monte en puissance on va
devoir peut-être prendre encore des
nouvelles mesures restrictives qui est
un qui vont avoir un impact sur sur
notre économie
donc c'est peut-être un peu tôt en tout
cas pour moi de d'envisager de maintenir
une réforme mais qui cela dit en fait ne
ne change pas n'est pas une
une réforme non plus structurelle c'est
quand même ça reste quand même des
aménagements à la marge pour satisfaire
l'union européenne et la zone euro il
n'y a pas de grands changements on voit
que c'est surtout sur les les chômeurs
qui gagne une allocation lv1 de plus
qu'est de 4500 brut par mois qui vont
avoir leur leur douleur tout leur temps
en ligne réduit sur voir ensuite ce
qu'attendait ya quand même l'unedic qui
nous dit que 1,15 million chômeurs vont
voir leurs allocations bcc c'est pas la
marge c'est pas une petite réforme alors
un prêt c'est ce qu'ils vont arriver
voilà c'est qu'on va pas toucher ceux
qui ça ne va pas toucher ceux qui
actuellement sont au chômage un c'est ce
qu'ils vont être inscrits les nouveaux
inscrits au chômage vont avoir des
modifications dans leur calcul de
l'indemnité 1 c'est pas rétroactif on va
pas dire ce qu'on va laisser les
allocations de ceux qui sont au chômage
en ce moment non non c'est hans adu est
ce qu'ils vont arriver sur un chômeur ou
alors c'est là si vous voulez en fait
c'est très intéressant parce que on dit
tout à l'heure sur la retraite c'est pas
clair bah oui là c'est pas clair je
crois que malheureusement le
gouvernement sa spécialité c'est de
devenir pas clair
donc j'essaie quand même l'impression
qu'il y ait un pacte avec le brouillard
mais je ne sais pas quand est-ce qu'il a
été signé mais il a eu lieu alors
essayons de voir clair quand tout
d'abord cette réforme des mains en
octobre mais la question bonus malus
ça va concerner les entreprises qu'en
septembre 2022 donc hop
donc si vous voulez déjà pour l'opinion
le signal est très mauvais c'est à dire
lorsqu'il s'agit de réduire un montant
d'indemnité chômage c'est maintenant
lorsqu'il s'agit de benali pénaliser un
bonus malus c'est après donc déjà au
delà même de ce qu'on peut penser de cet
effort en termes de communication c'est
désastreux
d'autre part avant de revenir sur les
chômeurs quand red star quelques
remarques
les contrats courts se concentrent dans
quelques activités spectacles cinéma
restauration en premier
or lorsqu'on lit le projet de loi le
bonus malus ne va pas concerner la
restauration donc alors on se dit
bonjour le problème voilà un secteur qui
usent utilisent pour des raisons bonnes
ou mauvaises peu importe des contrats
courts mais celui-là et touchera pas il
ne soit pas concerne pas le bonus malus
maintenant les chômeurs alors voilà ce
qui je suis désolé je vais être un peu
technique mais trop c'est trop on essaye
de viser si je suis fou modifié on va
modifier le calcul des droits au chômage
pour ceux qui vont entrer au chômage
accord à partir alors ça devait être le
1er juillet mais le gouvernement doit
retoqué ces règles puisque le conseil
d'état qui avait été saisi indique que
cette modalité de calcul il en suspens
dès l'application accord donc
admettons ils réussissent à retoquer
toute affaire donc vous l'individu a et
demain au chômage inscrits au pôle
emploi
il verra une fois que la loi est entrée
en vigueur ce qui va recevoir caen
indemnités sera pensé par rapport au
calcul de la nouvelle loi carif si vous
êtes par exemple au chômage avant et que
vous aviez par exemple jusqu'à 24 mois
de chômage
on va pas vous dire à manque de vols
vous n'aurez plus que 12 mois
parce que sinon il ya un principe
juridique la rétroactivité la loi ça
marche pas mais le problème c'est que le
calcul des nouveaux entrants centre et
la technique oui je ne vais pas le
flamand ça et bien va être beaucoup
moins favorable que par le passé donc
résultat des courses le gouvernement
essaye de s'en tirer en disant ah non
ils seront peut-être moins bien amusés
que par le passé mais ils ont une
indemnité plus longue donc ils essayent
de nous trouver un tour de passe passe
pour nous expliquer ils sont pas
complètement perdant le ski ça va durer
plus longtemps
mais le problème c'est que déjà
aujourd'hui il faut savoir 40 % des
chômeurs ne touchent pas d'indemnité
chômage
et qu'est ce qui devient une indemnité
chômage par défaut c'est le rsa parce
que petit point technique juste une fois
que l'un des mythes et chemin est finie
vous avez droit à certaines conditions
qu'on appelle la ss donc qui est comment
dire une allocation on peut vous donner
mais si vous avez certains critères qui
vous autorise à voir c'est à l'occasion
si vous pouvez pas avoir la ss une fois
qu'on a fini comme mondiale indemnités
chômage ou basculer sur le rsa donc
résultat dans la sphère on ne comprend
pas comment combat la précarité puisque
c'est ça le sens de cette loi en la
fabricant c'est à dire donc au lieu de
la réduire
on la campagne donc c'est vous laisser
aussi paradoxale que les lois pénicaud
qui avait dit pour créer de l'emploi il
faut faciliter le licenciement
on va laisser stéphanie je pense que
voulait exprimer très bien en fait c'est
c'est en fait ça ça reste quand même
encore une usine à gaz où il fait
effectivement prendre du temps et pour
essayer de comprendre où va cette
réforme ont fait cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais dans quel
objectif
on entend bien que derrière c'est pour
inciter retour au travail
effectivement il ya des peut-être des
niches avec des gens qui gagnent plus
d'argent au chômage que ceux qui alors
qu'en travaillons donc peut-être que ça
il faut corriger mais l'esprit même de
cette réforme
on a du mal à le comprendre étant donné
que ça reste technique et sa est de
l'écriture comptable
à la marge et à essayer de comprendre
voyez le le message adressé aux
aujourd'hui en fin de crise sanitaire on
l'espère en début de reprise
là aussi ça risque de braquer en fait
l'opinion publique qui s'attend à autre
chose qui s'attend effectivement on va
mettre des mesures pour aider leur pour
favoriser le retour à l'emploi et là on
pense aux jeunes qui n'ont pas n'ont pas
on vivre cette période avec une
incapacité de retrouver je vois
quelqu'un applaudir en visio parce qu'on
va y venir aux jeunes feu lui ment je
vous laisse finir donc voilà je pense
qu'il aurait été plus plus simple et
plus compréhensible pour tout ce qu'on a
dit qu'on adresse un message clair en
disant cette réforme vise à améliorer le
retour à l'emploi et ça on le comprend
pas en fait avec ce qui a été mis en
place
alors les jeunes effectivement revenons
sur ce que leur propose le chef de
l'état puisqu'il en a parlé des jeunes
plutôt que de le citer je préfère qu'on
réécoute ses mots
j'ai présenté à la rentrée le revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui
concernera les jeunes sans emploi ou
formation et sera fondé sur une logique
de devoir est de droit alors avant d'en
parler avec vous sur ce plateau
demandant un représentant de la jeunesse
ce qu'ils en pensent bon soir louis
boyard et bienvenue dans ce match des
idées vous êtes porte parole du
mouvement des solidarités étudiante
qu'est-ce qu'il vous inspire ce revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes sans emploi
sans formation
alors d'un côté je fais un peu optimiste
parce que il va s'inspirer sur la
garantie gène qu'un système on peut
beaucoup critiqué mais qui est quand
même relativement satisfaisant il compte
investir et élargir la guerre anti
jeunes mais alors où compte changer le
nom y imposer un plus de devoirs et
c'est là on en fait j'ai le sentiment
que emmanuel macron va changer un
système qui fonctionne pas trop mal pour
ajouter plus de sanctions et je pense
pas que ce soit la bonne solution je
pense pas non plus que ce soit le bon
message à envoyer aux jeunes mais c'est
aussi la principale crainte qu'on a tous
en fait on ne comprend pas on ne
comprend pas ce qu'il veut faire vous
comprends pas pourquoi est ce qui vous
touche à la garantie jeunes donc voilà
je suis comme beaucoup de gens
complètement perdus mais un peu inquiet
dans l'esprit pourquoi le fait qu'on
demande à un jeune de d2 voire puisqu'il
a des droits
vous choque-t-il alors déjà j'aimerais
rappeler que la garantie jeunes et
d'ailleurs sont revenus d'engagement
c'est une mesure qui est mis en place
parce qu'il ne veut pas ouvrir le rsa
aux jeunes en disant que beaucoup de
jeunes se complaît dans le rsa alors
pourquoi pas moi je suis absolument pas
d'accord avec ça mais alors dans ce cas
il devrait avec ce revenu d'engagements
donnés au moins le même revenu que le
rsa et les devoirs
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que la garantie
jeune elle impose certains devoirs mais
la philosophie ne repose pas sur ça la
guerre anti jeunes 90 % des jeunes sont
satisfaits de l'emploi dans lequel il se
trouve justement parce qu'on ne leur
mets pas une pression
j'ai peur que l'on se retrouve à cause
de ses devoirs et de ce chantage à la
location que des jeunes et à accepter
des formations ou des métiers dans
lesquels ils ne se plaisent pas et dans
lesquels il ne continueront pas alors
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'on ne met pas la
pression sur ses jeunes 90% des jeunes
qui trouvent une formation grâce à
à la garantie jeunes se disent
satisfaits donc je vois pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'on viendrait rajouter de la
pression
un système qui fonctionne déjà
correctement si vous demandez aux jeunes
je sais pas les services d aide à la
personne des choses comme ça quelques
heures par semaine ça vous ça vous
choquerait mais pourquoi pas à partir du
moment où le jeune on a envie en fait ce
dont ont besoin ces jeunes là d'ailleurs
un qui sont souvent on fait des jeunes
qui sont commis dans la vie disons ski
et ils savent pas dans quelle formation
s'orienter ils savent pas quel métier
faire
en fait tout ce qu'ils demandent c'est
de trouver une passion trouver quelque
chose avec lequel ils pourront être
utiles dans la société quelque chose qui
pourront faire toute leur vie c'est
l'objectif c'est juste d'effectuer
quelques missions d'intérêt général
alors on a échoué parce qu'on n'a pas
réussi à insérer le jeune dans le marché
du travail
si jamais l'objectif c'est de vraiment
prendre le temps de les accompagner de
ne pas leur mettre la pression de leur
dire vous avez le droit de vous tromper
pour trouver le métier de votre vie
alors là on aura réussi malheureusement
j'ai l'impression qu'ils emmanuel macron
il va plus sur la trajectoire du faire
en sorte que les jeunes trouvent le plus
rapidement possible d'emplois pour avoir
des chiffres corrects et pour voir
derrière se vanter pendant la campagne
présidentielle
plutôt que de vouloir pérenniser et
élargir un système qui privilégie le
fait que les jeunes doivent trouver le
métier de leur vie dans lequel ils se
sentiront bien rester avec nous le
voyeur on va en discuter en plateau et
je vous redonne la parole dans un
instant qu'en pensez vous de ce revenu
d'engagement à frédéric parent écoutez
comme l'a dit l'intervenant bon c'est un
système que l'on peut critiquer qui elle
mérite existé et qui existe parce
qu'aussi le rsa n'est pas ouvert aux
jeunes et ça dépend comment on quels
usages on en fait soit on rabat ou sur
la personne en disant que trouver un
emploi
saint céré c'est qu'une affaire
individuelle soit on articule sa avec
l'idée que pour créer de l'emploi il n'y
a pas à simplement votre volonté il y a
aussi des structures économiques et
sociales qui sont là il ya un niveau
d'activité une croissance ou y en a pas
il y avait effectivement l'accès à
certaines formations ou non tout n'est
pas qu'affaire d'individus si
effectivement c'est un accompagnement un
accomplissement on est les gens on les
forme et vous et cessez le mirage de 2,9
un peu de la formation c'est à dire de
dire une fois que vous êtes formés et
vous avez acquis des compétences
nécessaires
c'est bon vous trouverez un boulot et
bien vaut mieux être formé que ne pas
l'être
certes mais il y a aussi une situation
de marché du travail vous sortez sur le
marché du travail comme des jeunes qui
sont sortis en septembre 2020 alors
qu'on est en situation de crise et
autres c'est pas la même chose que si
vous sortez une année où par exemple
voilà prenons un exemple très concret
vous sortez sur une infiltration en 1998
alors que la france connaît une
croissance et autres vous êtes un jeune
que vous soyez plus ou moins bien formés
l'horizon économique est ouvert vous
sortez en septembre 2001 vous êtes au
coeur d'une pandémie qui n'est pas finie
et qui rentrait le traité va évidemment
même si vous avez toute la volonté du
monde de vous en sortir de vous former
et vous fait face à un mur économique et
c'est pas simplement votre personnalité
et votre engagement et eau et par
rapport à la question des devoirs
on parlait de flou c'est c'est comme au
pôle emploi quand vous regardez qu'est
ce qu'on attend des demandeurs d'emploi
qui fasse des recherches effective bon à
partir de quel moment c'est la recherche
effective quand vous avez écrit trente
lettres 28 l'être quand vous avez passé
des coups de téléphone
douze coups de téléphone et là on
nourrit le fou surtout que vous savez
qu'il ya plein d'entreprises vous pouvez
envoyer des lettres
ils vous répondent pas donc comment on
pourrait attester de votre bonne foi
comme quoi vous avez envoyé des lettres
à x ou y entreprises puisqu'il n'y a pas
de retour donc que l'on accompagne les
individus mais vous voyez bien c'est
tout un discours de méfiance que ce soit
sur l'assurance-chômage l'accompagnement
des jeunes il ya toujours ces espèces
dessous discours qui consiste à dire si
on jette pas un oeil sur ces gens ils
vont préférer plutôt les loisirs au
travail parce qu'il ya des abus ou pas
c'est vrai non mais c'est une question
vous en prie non mais je pense que de
toute manière c'est c'est mal formulé de
tous mais même en 98 les jeunes ont
toujours eu un problème bien sûr engrais
sur le marché de l'emploi allait le taux
de chômage des jeunes ces 20 % lorsque
c'est le double par rapport à
par rapport au taux de chômage moyen
donc en france on a cette difficulté
intégrés la jeunesse formée ou pas mais
enfin c'est vrai que vous m'ayez de
former sur le marché du travail donc je
pense que cette crise sanitaire a mis en
exergue dans un tout nos
dysfonctionnements les à amplifier
alors aujourd'hui on se dit que déjà à
l'époque quand tout allait bien en 98 on
avait du mal à rentrer sur le marché du
travail mais là ça va être encore plus
dur pour la jeunesse alors quelles
solutions à apporter à ces jeunes
alors lorsqu'on dit effectivement il y
aura une contrainte on va vous donner de
l'argent mais derrière il y aura une
contrainte
moi je trouve que c'est réducteur ça
nous ça met de côté en fait tout espoir
pour ces jeunes mais aussi pour notre
économie on est en pleine révolution
numérique on a pris un retard de dingue
pour reprendre une expression on est
aussi on va vers la transition
écologique les jeunes réclament cette
transition écologique l'environnement
reste au coeur de leurs priorités ou
derrière il ya effectivement il ya des
formations il ya des métiers je pense
qu'il aurait été plus stimulant
d'adresser un message à ces jeunes là en
disant vous êtes l'avenir de la france
il est on a un manque sur tel et tel
domaine on va vous former pour ça les
jeunes sont parfois heures et sont
demandeurs c'est eux qui tous les
vendredis avec greta lgbt ou mères sont
on était dans la rue pour né pour faire
bouger les lignes
aujourd'hui il faut répondre par la
formation et je pense que c'est ça moi
qui m'inquiète c'est que aujourd'hui on
ne discute pas des formations d'avenir
c'est à dire ceux qui vont perdre de ces
formations qui vont permettre à ces
jeunes d'avoir un an des intéressés qui
les intéressent et j'ai effectivement ce
système de 10 renvois vous donnez une
allocation mais derrière il y aura une
contrainte c'est le mot contrainte c'est
à dire qu'on n'a même pas rigoler de
voir le mot employé était celui de
devoir
réfléchis à là où on voulait emmener
notre notre nation alors je vous laisse
réagir le voyeur et ensuite je vous
donne la parole frédéric pas vous vous
demandiez pourquoi est ce qu'il ya eu ce
mot devoir mais il faut re cité cette
annonce dans un contexte dans une
allocution qui à la fois parler de la
crise sanitaire mais qui était aussi une
sorte d' allocution de créer précampagne
présidentielle où on a entendu parler de
travail de mérite de responsabilisation
individuelle et ce mot là pour moi il
n'a pas été adressée envers les jeunes
il a été adressée envers d'autres
tranches d'âge dont emmanuel macron
chercher à avoir leur vote
dire que les jeunes ont des devoirs tout
ça ça s'inscrivait dans un contexte de
drague politique 10 ans qui est ce
n'était pas un message adressé aux
jeunes ensuite pour réagir à ce que vous
disiez sur le fait que les jeunes
doivent s'adapter au marché du travail
oui bien sûr pour moi c'est ça ne vaut
même pas la peine de me dire ou de
l'expliquer tellement c'est une évidence
le monde fonctionne comme ça mais on a
trop tendance à dire que puisque le
marché du travail est ainsi les jeunes
devraient parfois accepter un métier
même si jamais c'est pas trop ce qu'ils
aiment faire sauf que ce qu'on voit
c'est que ces jeunes en général il se
retrouve à avoir besoin de la garantie
jeunes et donc bientôt du revenu
d'engagement ce sont souvent des jeunes
qui sont paumés dans la vie et qui n'ont
pas vraiment de passion et qui ont
besoin de s'accrocher à quelque chose et
trop souvent on leur donne une formation
qui ne veulent pas faire parce que ça
rend bien sûr les chiffres de comptes
rendus et qui permettent de faire des
bilans
deux ans plus tard ces gens ont
abandonné leur travail et on se repose
la question du rsa on se repose la
question de l'insertion à l'emploi
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est que à
utiliser le mot devoir par drag
politique et à mettre buzz des
contraintes qui en vérité ne sont pas
nécessaires parce que la guerre anti
jeunes montrent déjà que l'insertion
fonctionne j'ai l'impression qu'on va
détruire un système qui fonctionne très
bien
uniquement pour défendre des intérêts
électoraux et c'est ça qui inquiète la
plupart des gens frédéric farre âge
venant dé conclure en 40 secondes si
c'est possible
quarante secondes ce chiffre de 25% des
jeunes aux 20% des jeunes sont au
chômage
généralement concernant la catégorie 16
25 ans la plupart des 16 25 ans sont aux
études ceux qui sont sûrement ce travail
c'est les plus vulnérables et moins
formés dont plus exposés au chômage
donc c'est pour ça que ce chiffre le
plus important deuxièmement par rapport
à votre idée pourquoi le chômage au
début de la crise économique dans les
années 70 quand le chômage de masse est
revenu on a dit pourquoi elle dit
maj c'est parce que l'activité n'est pas
suffisante
comme ce chômage s'est maintenu dans le
temps on a changé notre regard et on a
dit mais nancy le chômage poursuit c'est
peut-être bien parce que les gens ils ne
veulent pas vraiment beau c'est donc
notre représentation du chômage a changé
je crois que la source principale de la
faire c'est le niveau d'activité qui
nous permettra à créer des emplois et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci à tous les
trois donc d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées merci louis paillard
merci à tous fin de cette émission on se
retrouve jeudi à 18 heures et à 22h30
pour la dernière de la saison je 17h30
bonjour chez vous au rayonnement de
chimie recevra notamment jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
excellente soirée sur public sénat